what is it about a psychic that you like
can buy into where do you have a
boundary talk to me okay truthfully true
well the truth is anybody that's going
to a psychic or somebody who's lost
somebody right and what I like about
psychics is who knows what happens in
the great beyond but if they can give
you something something to hold on to it
brings you peace and plus I'm just so
curious about what's next I mean it's so
great here what could be next that's
what I want to know and by the way next
time Teresa Caputo tell me when to buy a
scratcher for the love of God hello can
I
I don't know if they know what's going
on in the afterlife but if they can help
you win the lottery
yeah great listen to that I don't know
I'm curious I'm curious sometimes I tell
myself what's out there is so incredible
that you have to give your life up for
it
oh that's good Drew that's good I still
want to know though I still want to know
now